j'ai fait ce rêve incroyable d'avoir la
meilleure équipe qui existe est de
réaliser l'impossible
[Musique]
devenir champion olympique
très chers camarades vous allez
travailler avec un nouvel entraîneur
c'est quoi ça c'est mon équipe
je marque en moyenne 30 points par match
qui d'autre fait ça
ce
les russes vous comprenez jamais rien tu
fais combien en 100 m en 7 tu peux faire
beaucoup mieux que ça c'est pas avec
d'espoir aveugle que je vais gagner
dit rien à personne sinon ils ont viré
de l'équipe
est-ce que tu marques souvent
non pas trop et aux autres qui leur
passent souvent la balle bah oui c'est
voter comprendre non eh ben tu vas
comprendre
nous voulons battre les américains tu
dis souvent que c'est impossible je vais
tout faire pour qu'on arrive à les
battre
tu vas rencontrer toutes sortes d'ennuis
les gagnants remportent la médaille d'or
mais les perdants ont bien plus à perdre
que la première place peut-être qu'on ne
devrait pas jouer cet espoir c'est tout
ce que nous possédions je veux que vous
jouiez selon aurel ballmer
[Musique]
celui ci
temps comme un souffle de vie on peut
tout faire nous faisions partie de la
même équipe
thor est dit